- Huh?
- You don't wanna hold her?
- I'm okay.
- You think you should hold her.
- No, it's okay, it's okay.
- Shawn.
- No, guys, please, alright.
- Shawn's afraid to hold the baby.
- I am afraid to hold the baby, I don't.
- Shawn's afraid to hold da baby.
- I am afraid to hold the baby.
- Little baby, she's tough.
- I'm not frightened, I'm not frightened.
(loud dance music)
- Shawn Mendes is at BuzzFeed today
and he's here to let all
his Twitter followers
make his decisions for him.
Why are we talkin' about it?
Let's just start the video, let's do this.
Hey what up, how's it goin'?
- Hey, good.
- Nice to meet ya, Shawn.
- Thank you, you too man.
- Thanks for bein' here.
- Thank you.
- Let's get down to it.
- Alright.
- You just got off a tour.
- Mmm-Hmm.
- You been traveling all around,
performing for millions
and millions of people.
I thought, since you're here,
you could have all your fans
decide what you do at BuzzFeed.
- Scary.
- Yeah, I know it's kinda scary.
But you trust your fans.
- No, no, I trust 'em, I trust 'em.
- They're gonna take care of ya.
- They're gonna make me do
the weirdest possible thing.
- Yeah, probably.
- Yeah.
- So, your most popular song, Stitches,
it's about kissing and stitches.
So I thought we'd have you send a tweet.
- Yep.
- Asking your fans, should I do a video
where I kiss a bunch of people
or watch a video where
people actually get stitches?
- Get stitches, okay.
- How's your day been, by the way?
- Good, good.
- We just have to wait
ten minutes now, so.
- I hung out with Larry King
earlier, so, phenomenal.
- That's way more exciting
than me, I'm sure.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- Who's better looking,
who's better looking?
- Larry had this beautiful
hairstyle happening
so I'm sorry, he wins.
But you know...
(bell dings)
- Introduce yourself to the nice people,
ask 'em if it's okay to
give 'em a little kiss.
- Oh no.
- Give 'em a little kiss.
You can do it to anyone.
- Hi!
- Hi, can I please kiss
you on the forehead?
(laughs)
Thank you.
- Yeah.
- Can we have a hug?
- Yes, of course.
- I love you!
- Thank you.
Is it okay to kiss you on the forehead?
Just one quick kiss on the forehead.
- Sure.
- Thank you.
Hi, I promise you this is just as weird
for me as it is for you guys.
(laughs)
- Sure.
- So do you like a kiss on the forehead?
One.
Can I kiss you?
- Yeah.
- Thank you!
(laughs)
Ma'am, can I please kiss
you on the forehead?
(laughs)
- Sweet.
- Also...
- Aw.
- This is an awesome fact,
I'm extremely allergic to dogs.
- Then why would you kiss
a dog on the forehead?
- It was completely spontaneous
and I dunno, so we'll see.
- I also like how you grabbed
everyone's head so physically.
May I get a taste?
Oh wow, that's nice.
We're gonna go to another room,
we're gonna set up your next tweet.
- I probably should go wash
my face 'cause of the dog.
- Why, oh the dog.
- Yeah.
- I was about to say like,
those people aren't that
dirty, you don't need to...
- No, you guys are clean.
- The dog.
- The dog is probably clean too.
- Yeah, 'cause you're allergic.
You're lips are really itchy?
- A little itchy.
- I'm sorry about that.
You're Canadian.
- Yeah.
- You probably know a lot about Canada.
- Mmm-Hmm.
- So I'd like to--
(laughs)
- As much as I--
- You were very confident,
then not at all.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna have your
Twitter fans decide which way
I'm gonna challenge you on
your Canadian knowledge.
- Okay.
- So, you can either label a Canadian map,
you can try to identify a fact
that's not true about Canada.
Or you can try to spot a
Canadian in a lineup of people.
- Alright.
- Okay, we gotta wait five minutes now
and then we're gonna see
how Canadian you really are.
How Canadian do you think you are?
- Not that, well like very Canadian.
- Yeah, you're not a Canadian scholar.
- No.
(bell dings)
(clock ticking)
- So your first fact is, you can actually
call the Canadian government
at 1-800-0-CANADA.
- Right.
- There is a small fishing village
in Newfoundland named Dildo.
(laughs)
Your third fact is, a 2013
poll found that 27 percent
of Canadian participants
believe that hipsters
should be forced to pay a
special tax for being annoying.
- How could, how does anybody know these?
Honestly, like, if there
was a place in the world
that there would be a town named Dildo,
it would be in Newfoundland.
But also, like, that's a
very Canadian thing to do
is to have 1-800-0-CANADA, so.
- Hold up the one you think is fake.
- I hope hipsters don't
get offended by me,
by saying that I think this is fake.
- You think Oh Canada's fake?
- Yeah.
- Oh Canada's true.
(sad band music)
It's hipsters is fake.
And it's actually an American poll,
found that we believe
there should be a tax.
- Oh thank God it's an American thing.
- Yeah, but you still got it wrong.
Okay, so we're gonna
move on to the next poll.
We have a little bit of time.
Are you hungry at all?
- If you're hungry...
- Would you wanna go, maybe
go get some fast food?
Okay, so we're about to go.
We're gonna send out a
tweet, you're gonna decide
whether or not you're
going to sing your order,
whether or not you order 20 things,
or if you're gonna pay for
a normal order in pennies.
Boom, there it is.
- Alright.
Yeah.
I'm sorry, I keep itching my nose
but there's dog hair in it.
- I'm sorry.
Alright, don't put this all on me.
I'll take some of the blame
but at the end of the
day, you kissed the dog.
(bell dings)
Sing your order.
- I knew it.
- I mean, you're a singer.
That's what they want.
- Okay.
- There's hamburgers, cheeseburgers.
Don't get the chili on it, it's too much.
- Hi!
♫ Can I please get
♫ A hamburger with chili on top
♫ And maybe some cheese
fries with that, yeah
- Wow, that's beautiful.
♫ That would be all, thank you
(laughs)
- I decided to get chili, just for you.
- I said not to get the chili!
- Thank you so much.
♫ Thank you
(quiet digital music)
- There's way too much
chili on this, Shawn.
I said I didn't want it.
Ugh, oh the chili ruins it.
- What's next?
- Oh, you're gonna go sing to a baby.
- Okay.
(laughs)
What song should I sing to a baby?
- How about Twinkle Twinkle Little Star?
- [Shawn] Twinkle.
- Do you know Rockabye Baby?
- Yep.
- Is that a Canadian song?
The Itsy Bitsy Spider,
do you know that one?
- Yep.
- That's (loud beep) solid.
Alright, great, you sent out the poll.
So we'll find out what
we sing to the baby.
It's the cutest little baby.
- As long as you're gonna sing to me,
'cause I don't want the baby to judge me.
- You want me to sing to you or with you?
- With the baby.
- With--
- No, with me to the baby.
- Make up your mind, Shawn.
- With me to the baby.
- I will sing with you to the baby.
Flynn, this is Shawn Mendes.
- We're gonna sing to you, okay?
Nice to meet you, Flynn.
I heard lots about you,
I'm a very big fan.
- I'm gonna sit down here,
I'm gonna sit on this.
- Are you sure?
- Oh, you want some milk?
Ready?
- Okay.
(laughs)
♫ Twinkle, twinkle little star
♫ How I wonder what you are
♫ Up above the sky so high
♫ Up above the sky so bright
(laughs)
♫ Like a diamond in the sky
♫ Twinkle, twinkle little star
♫ How I wonder what you are
- This is the smartest
baby I've ever seen.
- I didn't realize there
was a Canadian version
and an American version.
- I didn't think there,
I don't think there is,
I think I got the lyrics wrong.
(laughs)
- I think there's, this is wrong.
- Anyways, thank you for
being such a good baby.
- Isn't she cute?
- Yeah, I think if I was a baby
and this was happening to me,
I'd be screaming and crying.
- She's chuggin' that milk.
- Chug, chug, chug
- Chug, chug.
- I think you should hold her.
- No no no, it's okay, it's okay.
- Shawn.
- No, guys, please, alright?
- Shawn's afraid to hold the baby.
- No, see, I am afraid to
hold the baby, I don't...
- Shawn's afraid to hold da baby.
- I'm afraid a little bit.
This is actually...
- We look like an adorable couple.
- Yeah, we do.
- With a little baby.
(laughs)
- We do.
And I'm like the one that's
scared to hold the baby.
- I know.
You wanna give her a kiss on the forehead?
- Sure, you get a kiss.
Thank you.
- Aw!
Shawn, I hate to break it you but
this video has to end soon.
- No, it doesn't!
- Yeah, it does.
You have to leave, you have to go on
and do bigger and better things, Shawn.
- I do.
- So, I thought we'd let your
Twitter followers decide
how this video ends.
And I thought maybe, either we could have
an all-out break up scene,
we could have a passionate,
long hug goodbye.
- Yep.
- Or we could do a Where
Are They Now sequence.
Five minute poll, we're gonna
find out how this video ends
and then we're just gonna cut
to the ending they choose.
- I'm gonna be a good dad.
- Yeah.
I appreciate it.
- That really came out of nowhere.
(laughs)
(bell dings)
- So you always get to clap.
- Well it's just how we
sync the camera, Shawn,
it's not supposed to be a big thing.
- Fine, I get it, you work here,
you always get to do the clap.
- It's not like that, Shawn!
- You don't wanna give it to other people.
- You know it's not like that!
- You know what, today
has just been wrong.
- It's been wrong?
- Yeah!
- I invite you over to my company
to make a video for your
fans and I did wrong?
- You forced me to kiss
people on the forehead
and you know I didn't want
to kiss them on the forehead!
- I thought you would like it,
you have a song about kissing, Shawn!
- Not on the forehead!
- Well, I don't know!
Maybe I'm jealous.
- And it was mostly, I
was upset in the song.
- Maybe I'm just dumb, Shawn!
- Don't say that!
- Maybe I'm just dumb!
- No.
(crying)
Come here.
(dramatic emotional music)
- You film this?
- Come on, Shawn!
Let's get outta here.
- Goodbye, Shawn Mendes.
I'll never forget you.
(sighs)